die korona app hat ein update bekommen
das den nutzer nun nach und nach zur
verfügung gestellt wird
es sind zwei neue funktionen von denen
sich die macher und die politik mehr
sicherheit und kontrolle versprechen
zum einen wird die app nun über
deutschlands grenzen hinaus in etlichen
weiteren europäischen ländern
funktionieren
zum anderen können positiv getestete
nutzer freiwillig eine art tagebuch über
ihre symptome führen das soll helfen zu
bestimmen wie infektiös die betroffenen
sind und so die warnungen der app
genauer machen etwa 20 millionen mal
wurde die anwendung bereits in
deutschland heruntergeladen
experten gehen von einer aktiven nutzung
von etwa 16 millionen menschen aus
bekommt man eine nachricht über einen
kontakt mit einem corona positiv
getesteten menschen sagt die app was die
nächsten schritte sind und tatsächlich
berichten immer mehr nutzer über
gestiegene warnungen das bestätigt auch
kanzleramtsminister helge braun
die app ist kein werkzeug zur bekämpfung
der pandemie
das wissen auch die macher trotzdem
hoffen sie diese dadurch besser
beherrschen zu können
[Musik]
wir sind bild und wir liefert dir deine
news auf youtube zum nächsten video
kommst du hier
und vergesst bitte nicht unseren kanal
zu abonnieren